hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at [ __ ]
boys but this time I did a lot of
farming I did a lot a lot of farming but
I'm gonna be a responsible adult and I'm
not gonna take a double shot this time
because I know my limits and I know
what's dangerous for me and I know
what's good for me and if you are ever
drinking agent are participating I hope
that you were drinking responsibly and
please for the love of God don't even
think about driving or doing anything
stupid like calling your ex that's a
terrible idea don't do it don't even
techno now put the phone down put phone
down all right here we go
we have a good time here I mean for you
these are days apart but for me it's
like one after the other after another I
mean this is me playing by myself
talking to a load I've been doing this
for three goddamn years but I'm still
cheering a camera so too do you know I
said they were getting less tasty over
time it's actually getting tastier over
time that's number six right there
that's number six for me ha oh boy so I
farmed as much as I can Freddie's got
his microphone I could not get chicas
cupcake I'm guessing from the Omega
unless I did and I forgot about it I've
no idiot I do not know okay so I really
don't know I've optimized everyone as
best I can I've got everything that I
could possibly do I think that I'm good
I think that I'm okay so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to this kind of try
to be balloon boy because I I imagine
the balloon boy doesn't seem all that
intimidating so possibly balloon boy
might be the easiest of them all a hello
friend would you like
[Music]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] well that's
what I said Fox it Jesus
Wow okay okay I wanted to buy things
from you I thought that possibly would
have something else to sell me I didn't
even think about that inhale my dong
I'll inhale your dong boy Freddy
ooh listen to the soothing beats of
these royalty free copyright free music
lies some tasty beats right there okay
so I need to not be here or I need to
not be a stupid so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna do this as best I can
which probably doesn't mean much but I'm
gonna walk the plank be paralyzed you
[ __ ] yeah he's paralyzed
oh [ __ ] damn it none of us did anything
um I already did that I don't want to
rush down just friggin scream in his
face be done with it blam-blam-blam-blam
I think I can beat this guy cuz I mean I
I have not been doing what I needed to
do which was everything else but what I
need to do now is be as damaging as
possible what is guitar smash removes
all guitars from a image does that
include the kingly guitars that I had
I'll save that for later like there's a
final desperate move against an enemy
that I think I'm gonna lose against Oh
yep that's it nothing okay he's still
god damn this is awesome he's despair
why have I not been paralyzing people
before this is like the stupidest thing
okay so whatever whatever whatever I'm
going to give this to foxy I'm going to
bunny hop on his head yes god this is so
much easier now that I know how to
control the battle and actually do what
I need to to to
oh you he's no longer paralyzed as of
now so I don't think I don't think that
I can paralyze him again because I tried
that before in the other fight and it
did not work so I'm just gonna try to do
as much damage as I possibly drive to
the possibly can nobody that'll be then
before puppet gets to me oh man but I
hope I just don't know at this point
it's gonna be iffy yeah all right cool
ok so this is good right no I got to be
quicker about this rush down check oh
[ __ ] chica was not doing good I didn't
even notice that
go go go go go go go come on we don't
have the time for this go go go go go
yes yes chicas down but that's fine I
can get you get back up
okay so Freddy you're gonna do your
thing foxy you're pretty much out of
stuff so we're gonna put a cake I bought
a lot of items by the way I bought a lot
of items you do that and also it's
important to take advantage of knowing
when exactly things are gonna happen yes
practically easy yeah feels good when
I'm actually able to know what I'm doing
got about damn time why am I still
getting experience if I can't level up
learn to fazbear's gumbo if I can get
everybody's combo that's gonna be good
but I've never had my green meter
actually get up to the point where I
could use it but that's besides the
point whatever I don't mind it's all
good in my book okay so now the only
thing left is toy Bonnie and then mangle
I'm gonna take a look at mangle first
just because I have a feeling that it's
gonna be bad but I don't know it's gonna
be bad so might as well try I mean who
knows Bonnie could be the best because
Bonnie is kind of my heart is hitting
foxy hoods hits hard don't get me wrong
huh foxy it's very hard okay so now
we're all full up we're ready to go
ready to rock let's go fight mangle
learn the foxy combo
what is it with foxy and masturbating I
mean just jack it off when things aren't
happening well I guess it is technically
after our saw whatever hey if megawatts
to try to check off is misplaced Robo
deco oh really facts if you want to say
oh really
mangle oh [ __ ] the puppet I forgot about
the puppet ah titty bags God the puppet
an idiot whatever your answers I got a
die I have to die because there's no way
that I would be able to beat him in the
time limit that I have so I got a guy to
do boo damn it damn it damn it come on
just kill me already get it over with
yes take jig up I know I know I know
angle is X pretty tough that's it that's
it that's it
so holy God okay okay so now I'm gonna
go to the puppet because I'm not a
ranking that well I am a freaking idiot
apparently but then again I've also had
six shots of cinnamon whiskey yeah okay
now we're go tell your weight snowboard
somewhere I don't know mega steep stuff
let me go fight toy Bonnie this time I
mean I mean how am I supposed to be
golden Freddy like it's such a [ __ ]
alright whatever you know what whatever
forget it I'm gonna forget that it's
actually unfair and I'm just gonna try
as if it is fair walking the plank here
bastard okay that doesn't nothin
bunny hop on your bunny face get on to
plank damn it didn't work [ __ ] you did a
lot to Bonnie there what you got a oh
he's got so much different fence oh
seven damage there's nothing what a dick
right so
so foxy
I think foxy has to do if I want to win
this I got to make sure I get the timing
down
I don't think chica even has time to do
anything and chica just like no damage
ahh
Bonnie's all healed up better in better
god damn it foxy why Bonnie you're so
quick it's such a stupid [ __ ] oh god
this sucks okay whatever um Bonnie would
be the next in line so but chica also is
useless so I kind of want Bonnie to be a
bit Oh God such a hopeless piece of
blank you [ __ ] he'll walk the plank
become paralyzed please god damn it oh
this is so bad
okay at least [ __ ] healed up good great
rush him down no make it more I need him
paralyzed I really really need please
God
okay okay so maybe I can't imperil eyes
them as much as I want I just need to
let it actually happen okay so you do
that you rush him down and you actually
can heal so you do your thing you
bunnyhop he's paralyzed we're good we
got this in the bag baby it's all about
items strategy I'm not [ __ ] up that's
Mark Millar's keys to success vanity
whatever the sex is I'm not [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up
whatever screw it you know Toby whatever
I don't know what I'm talking about
anymore Giggy give okay that's good okay
oh boy toy Bonnie isn't paralyzed
anymore that's okay because we're gonna
do it this way you better he's got to be
getting close to dead but he may not be
actually dead who knows about that I
have no goddamn idea I go okay God he
attacks before my bunny does that's a
problem foxy is the first guy to go
goddamn it doesn't do anything okay so
what I gotta do is I gotta I think
Freddy is the Freddy no Bonnie's faster
than Freddy so tough one
I'm just gonna have a back-up plan in
case he kills Bonnie I'm gonna have
chica also try the cake foxy
whoa that was close
okay so I didn't need to do the
duplicate anyway so cheated yeah with
whatever is fine
so hit him hard foxy is going to help
you because you need help
chica is going to help foxy no chicas
gonna help no chicas gonna help herself
no foxy [ __ ] foxy is gonna help you
chicas gonna help foxy Bonnie's gonna
[ __ ] you finally holy [ __ ] bags [ __ ] ass
piss balls oh boy it's like not
rewarding at all like the bonbon combo
sure I'm sure that's phenomenal I've
never been able to use it well let's say
just haven't been paying attention I
have no idea I probably haven't been
baited I'm sure that when they die they
lose all their points but then again I
haven't been paying attention so maybe
it's not that gays and maybe I haven't
been doing the thing I needed to do know
this left is due to the father get to
the Papa get that oh my god get to the
puppet get to the puppet oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
ass and piss balls don't get me in a
random encounter please oh oh
no it's not okay that was panic that I
did not need at that moment okay now
that we're not about today
seriously that sent my heart going a
million miles an hour more than
Edgecumbe scared oh no any more okay I
need more medium so does this what I
need maybe these guys old mediums
inhale my dong [ __ ] [ __ ] okay okay
okay I just need to beat Mangal I need
how would anyone be able to beat this on
the harder difficulties that's what I
don't understand like the harder
difficulties have got to be nearly
impossible there's no way there's
alright so what I need to do is I need
to gear up for Mangal because I want to
be sure that I beat Mangal also before I
bring anyone else I don't wanna I don't
want to go to xxx night cuz goddamn I
don't have the my liver can't handle all
of them shots okay take this approach
very calmly and consciously you're gonna
be paralyzed that's for damn sure
now we're gonna do good okay so I need
to be relatively fast about this you're
gonna walk the plank
chicas gonna scream in your face gonna
do nothing bunnyhop blah blah please yes
god damn right off the bat that's
awesome I love that I love that a lot
and he takes a lot of babies he's x4
Davison bunny this guy might have been
actually easier than bunny was okay so
rush him down scream Adam skills bunny
huh okay we got this we got this in the
bag we gotta gotta gotta gotta go okay
we're good good good good
whoo no I was so where I think this is
because I was panicking because the
puppet was just about to kill me so this
is actually a lot better rush him down
why not I've got plenty of potential for
mana okay I'll be right back I won't
make you sit through this unless
something bad happens oh come on I just
resurrected Freddie you son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you mangle yeah piece of [ __ ] no
goddamnit [ __ ] Freddie stop that you
piece of [ __ ] you're such a piece of
[ __ ]
please [ __ ] oh don't do that to me
okay didn't work on either of this will
just take a mulligan on that and forget
it ever happened
no no paralyze no no no you kid bag [ __ ]
goddamn it so much damage [ __ ] die
already
Jesus dam kill him kill him kill him
kill him kill him please come on kill
him
[ __ ] oh no not okay it's fine it's fine
we're fine
oh we're [ __ ] fine that's what we are
Pat's bear combo I can do this okay I
can do this I can do the combos now I
can actually do the combos that's
actually really cool Bonnie do your
[ __ ] combo do it
chica that's fine did she get okay cue
scream waa I'm gonna I'm gonna run into
the puppet now
heyo yo he's dead a [ __ ] halt I'm gonna
be dead greats greats just great [ __ ]
just let me let me pockets goddamn duck
I fine you know what I'm gonna take this
seriously because [ __ ] you cuz she has
got a ability but I don't know if it's
gonna do anything
Oh No thank you for the Sephiroth theme
I like that a lot
[Music]
so hard I just want to beat him come on
I can beat him I know I can I know I can
I think I can I think I can stop
masturbating let me beat you off oh
[Music]
please paralyzed God deal never mind
never mind never mind I meant to say
something but when in reality I just
said never mind whatever it's okay I'm
gonna get caught by the puppet again a
[ __ ] gun who's gonna kill it this is
gonna kill him and then I'm gonna get
caught by the puppet this is gonna kill
him I'm gonna get caught I [ __ ]
called it and then I'm gonna be killed
by the goddamn puppet one okay all right
he wouldn't get peril is he like immune
to paralyze or something like that is he
just
one more try I'm gonna get it this time
I got a feeling about this one I got a
feeling about this one
yes finally you're [ __ ] frozen you
[ __ ] it's about goddamn time
holy [ __ ] Oh ridiculous trying to get
that one goddamn thing to happen win
this because he's foxy
okay he's no longer paralyzed good we're
right at the beginning of this [ __ ] we
can get him though he's always he's
gotta be almost at he's got to be pretty
close okay chicas paralyzed
that's all right whatever he's gotta be
almost dead it's got to be almost why
you got a triple head foxy like that why
can't you triple it one of the other
ones then we can get a combo yes okay
yes okay with this I stop complaining
I'm okay with this good God finally just
give me how to give me a gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme go okay oh yeah we
just gotta get man that was goddamn dick
ulis Jeepers Creepers ho posed opals
holy macaroni salad on bun [ __ ] knock
you are an a-hole I'm gonna go to the
puppet and now I've got everybody's
Limit Breaks so that means that I can
finally finally beat
Goldin [ __ ] Freddie oh my god that
took way too long okay let me just heal
everyone I'm pretty much done for this
episode because holy [ __ ] in a biscuit
only biscuit shit's okay
alright alright
so I've all done with this episode of
holy hell that was nuts but either way
thank you everybody so much for watching
this and putting up with my [ __ ]
that happened there wasn't even my
[ __ ] it was the [ __ ] of the
goddamn game but anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you
[Music]